in the collection
how many of these do we have now i think
i think it's hard not to say too many
however many it is it's objectively too
many where are they where do you keep
them i've just been saying i think
people have been asking that but i have
two little kids at home so this is not
so i keep them in a cupboard away from
them
so i
keep them wherever they are not
because
they're not safe around little ones i
love it i know it never gets old but
when like what is that moment like right
before the envelope when they open the
envelope and right before a name is
called your name it's the most bizarre
feeling
and i'm made even more bizarre by the
fact when i saw steve martin and minus
short walking out they're not presenting
our category that seems like
they are slumming it in an absolutely
ludicrous way
so to get to meet i met marty short
before
to me steve martin was wild we were back
here and i was looking i was like
they're just perfection they're just
perfection
yeah and like if you like if you grew up
loving comedy like to a character floor
extent
then
i knew his albums off by heart like that
born standing up book that he wrote was
incredible so to get to meet him or be
it for three seconds was uh a thrill
john you know i have to have asked about
world events because you're here yes
huge change going on in england right
now um
what what are you making talking about
liverpool's
exactly right i think i think klopp is
is going to have to change some things
it seems like he's into jude bellingham
can you say
king charles the third like does it
sound it's right no no it's gonna the
whole thing is going to be a huge
adjustment i mean there's 29 billion
coins with her face on it that's going
to have to change so yeah it's going to
be a process wow i did not know that
yeah she's on all the currency so
they're going to have to gradually phase
in his face um yes yes it's a very odd
way to decide to structure your that is
your country it is i mean it is bit of a
seismic shift yeah and like
you know i'm not sure how everybody
receives him but it's
i don't even know it i think the queen
was universally beloved and i think you
could the nicest thing about
prince charles or king charles now is
that he is less so right so uh i think
he's probably got a monumental pr
exercise not quite as much as his
brother uh to undergo but uh
yes it's uh it'll be it's gonna be a
very strange time in britain now you
straddle both of our worlds the news
world and the entertainment world in
your show what did you make of harry
megan uh prince
well he's not prince anymore yes he is
prince will he's the prince of wales
he got bumped from cambridge to wales
yeah there you go it all makes a lot of
sense what did you make of that i've
seen them all together
i made almost nothing of it i don't i
don't know i mean they went i have no
idea i get i think we'll see from
harry's book what's actually going on
that book
are you ready for it are we ready are
they ready for it is the biggest
question i did notice one thing and i
thought it was interesting harry and
megan walk out holding hands yes um
william and catherine did not is that
pro is that british protocol for like
royals
that's just british
that's just a fear of anyone invading
your personal space including your
spouse
so the most british thing you can do
really is never express your love for
any other human being and then do them
the dignity of dying so that's how you
do it there you go
i love it so much you are the best
congratulations
i really want you to count and next time
i see you i want to know
the number yes i'll just try not to
bring it with a four-year-old attached
to it
thanks a lot thank you